há um tempo atrás numa viagem de avião
eu sentei confortavelmente numa poltrona
da classe econômica e uma senhorinha se
sentou do meu lado
ela se virou pra mim toda simpática e
perguntou você não é o menino da lava
jato
muitas pessoas nos param na rua para
dizer não desistam vocês representam
perseverem e essa senhorinha simpática
virou sorrindo pra mim e disse ah meu
filho isso aí não vai dar certo
ela me fez lembrar daquela hiena hardy
dos desenhos animados não se lembra o
que mesmo que ela falava os céus vida ó
azar
isso não vai dar certo você conhece
alguém assim que perdeu as esperanças
que acredita que o brasil não tem jeito
é possível nós vencemos a desesperança e
nós derrotarmos a grande corrupção
impregnado nas nossas instituições
mas isso depende de nós
nós podemos reduzir o sofrimento humano
causado pela corrupção mortes em
estradas ruins desigualdade de
oportunidades
falta de segurança pública escolas
péssimas doenças causadas por falta de
água tratada e esgoto aflição em filas
de hospitais e tantos outros problemas
lutar contra a corrupção é uma questão
de justiça social de compaixão e de
realização de direitos humanos
por isso hoje nós vamos falar sobre
sonhar perseverar e usar na luta contra
a corrupção no brasil
bom eu vou começar pelo sonho quando eu
saía da faculdade há 15 anos atrás eu
tinha um sonho de um brasil melhor
mas mais do que isso eu queria
contribuir para ele o caminho que
encontrei para isso foi a carreira de
procurador da república
meu objetivo era nos casos criminais
alcançar a justiça e com isso ajudar a
evitar a roubalheira e recuperar o
dinheiro desviado
em 2004 eu tive o meu primeiro grande
caso de corrupção
identificamos mais de 70 funcionários
fantasmas na assembléia legislativa do
estado do paraná
o dinheiro dos salários era desviado
pelo esquema
passados mais de 13 anos adivinhe o que
aconteceu
nenhuma pessoa foi punida e nenhum
centavo foi recuperado um ano depois em
2005 eu passei a trabalhar no caso
banestado
acusamos mais de 680 pessoas por crimes
graves
sabem quantas foram presas pouco mais e
dez menos de 2%
em seguida no novo caso réus foram
condenados inclusive preocupção apenas
que superaram 40 anos de prisão
agora tudo seria diferente contudo em
os processos todos tinham ido por água
abaixo por questões puramente formais
a minha história parecida com a do
brasil num ponto é uma história de
fracassos na luta contra a corrupção
o estudo mostra que 97 a cada 100 casos
de corrupção comprovada a cabo em plena
impunidade
as engrenagens do sistema de justiça
criminal estão concatenado ajustadas
para não funcionar contra os poderosos
foi nesse contexto que no início de 2014
eu fui convidado para entrar na lava
jato em casa até então desconhecido que
era apenas uma montanha de trabalho
como vocês vêem eu tinha várias razões
para dizer não afinal de contas nada que
eu tinha feito até então tinha adiantado
alguma coisa na vida todos nós teremos
frustrações correndo atrás dos nossos
sonhos
muitas vezes você não decide o que
acontece com você mas você decide a sua
atitude diante do que acontece com você
diante dessas frustrações eu poderia
amargar e desistir mas eu decidi não
desistir
eu decidi perseverar e aceitei o convite
isso me deu o privilégio de fazer parte
de uma grande equipe de agentes públicos
que decidiu usar por meio de um novo
modelo de investigação com o trabalho
inovador nesse equipe
o apoio da sociedade e uma série de
sortes foi possível avançar contra a
corrupção e revelar um imenso esquema
criminoso como esse esquema funcionava
grandes empresas se articularam para
inflar contratos bilionários com a
petrobras
elas pagavam propina para aumentar os
seus lucros
do outro lado o interesse de agentes
públicos kasawaki desses empresários
políticos e partidos escolheram a dedo
funcionários altos executivos da
petrobras justamente para aqueles
arrecadassem propina
o suborno fluir para campanhas
eleitorais e para o bolso dos envolvidos
os recursos e um dos empresários até os
agentes públicos por meio de lavadores
de dinheiro profissionais que fazia o
dinheiro sujo para ser limpo
as investigações comprovaram o pagamento
de mais de 6 bilhões de reais em propina
se que os prejuízos da petrobras
estimados em até 42 bilhões como
resultado apenas em curitiba
282 pessoas foram acusadas por crimes
como corrupção lavagem de dinheiro e
organização criminosa
cento e sete já foram condenadas a penas
que somam mais de 1600 anos de prisão
muitas dessas pessoas eram e são
poderosas dentre eles seis parlamentares
um ex presidente da câmara dos deputados
em brasília apenas a colaboração do de
bresh explicou quase um terço dos
senadores e ministros e quase metade dos
governadores
além da punição os criminosos estão
sendo recuperados aos cofres públicos
mais de 10 bilhões de reais com a regra
no brasil não recuperar nenhum centavo
do que lava jato revelou na petrobras já
é muito grave mas as provas trouxeram à
tona o monstro ainda mais assustador
esquemas semelhantes
espalhados em vários órgãos federais
estaduais e municipais
descobriu-se que políticos e partidos
desonestos escolhe para cargos de
direção de órgãos públicos pessoas
incumbidas de arrecadar propina
o dinheiro e enriquece os criminosos e
financia caras campanhas eleitorais
garantindo a reeleição ou seja a
corrupção alavanca a permanência dos
corruptos do poder o que gera mais
corrupção o que gera mais permanência
dos corruptos do poder formando se um
círculo vicioso que deturpa democracia e
torna a sociedade brasileira prisioneira
da corrupção
o esquema da petrobras portanto apenas a
ponta de um gigantesco iceberg
estima se que a corrupção desvia no
brasil 200 bilhões de reais por ano
bilhões isso me traz a um ponto fulcral
não importa se você é de esquerda de
direita de centro de cima de baixo de
lado você tem algo importante para fazer
com 200 bilhões
você poderia por exemplo triplicar o
orçamento federal e saúde ou educação ou
multiplicar por cinco tudo que tivesse
segurança pública no nosso país
se você quer um país melhor
não há como alcançá lo se nós
enfrentarmos esse problema e pela
primeira vez as coisas começaram a dar
certo
agora o que a lava jato faz é um
diagnóstico mas não basta diagnóstico
nós precisamos de tratamento a corrupção
sistêmica pode ser comparado ao
apodrecimento de maçãs no barzinho
barril
o problema não é resolvido simplesmente
retirando as maçãs podres
é preciso mudar as condições de luz
temperatura e umidade que fazem as maçãs
apodrecerem muitas pessoas acreditam que
a lava jato vai transformar o brasil mas
é preciso ir além da lava jato
isso nos leva ao final do ano de 2014
quando para atacar causas centrais da
corrupção
foram desenvolvidos propostas
legislativas que ficaram conhecidas como
dez medidas contra a corrupção
elas foram uma iniciativa inédita e
ousada do ministério público em conjunto
com a sociedade civil
o seu objetivo era prevenir a corrupção
reduzir a impunidade recuperar o
dinheiro desviado
elas alcançaram apoio de mais de 2
milhões de brasileiros que por meio das
suas assinaturas acionar o projeto de
lei de iniciativa popular em 2016
enquanto o brasil chorava a tragédia que
vitimou o time de futebol da chapecoense
a tragédia do avião na calada da
madrugada
a câmara dos deputados destruiu as
propostas
no lugar das medidas anticorrupção foi
aprovado um projecto que objetivava
amarrar as investigações
novamente nós podemos amargar e desistir
lembre que muitas vezes na vida você não
decide o que acontece com você mas é
você quem disse e qual é a sua atitude
diante do que acontece com você
nós poderíamos amargar e desistir mas eu
decidi perseverar
de lá pra cá contudo tenho visto muitas
pessoas amargarem para piorar a situação
e uma sucessão de notícias ruins se
acumularam que soam como mais fracassos
na luta contra a corrupção
malas de dinheiro circula um ano depois
de iniciada a lava jato ministro solta e
resolve políticos e corruptos poderosos
regras que beneficiarão corruptos
gestadas no congresso nacional
há rumores de que o supremo tribunal
emitirá decisões que ficaram imensos
retrocessos
essa sucessão de fracassos alimenta
dentro de nós um inimigo poderoso dos
nossos sonhos que é a desesperança para
nós entendermos como a desesperança tua
vamos viajar um laboratório da
universidade de pensilvânia no inverno
de 1965 lá pesquisadores começaram
experimento com cachorros que embora
seja desagradável e eticamente
questionável tem uma preciosa lição a
nos ensinar cachorros de um primeiro
grupo foram colocados dentro de um
compartimento um de cada vez em que eles
sofriam choques elétricos regularmente
eles eram capazes de parar os choques
tocando um painel com o seu focinho o
que eles aprendiam de modo rápido
já os cachorros e um segundo grupo foram
colocados dentro do mesmo compartimento
mas nada que eles fizessem era capaz de
parar os choques em seguida os
cientistas colocaram os mesmos cachorros
dentro de um novo compartimento com duas
partes separadas por uma pequena cerca
uma parte dava choques ea outra não
agora os cachorros foram colocados de um
lado da cerca e bastava pular para o
outro lado para que eles escapassem dos
choques
adivinha o que aconteceu com os
cachorros do experimento anterior foram
colocados neste compartimento duplo os
cachorros do primeiro grupo aqueles que
tinham sido capazes de parar o choque
rapidamente pularam a cerca
contudo a maioria dos cachorros do
segundo grupo aqueles que tinham tomado
choques que não poderiam ser parados
simples nem de se deitaram no chão
eletrificado à espera de mais choques
eles não tentaram pular a cerca nem
qualquer outra solução eles se renderam
o psicólogo martin ser mãe era um dos
pesquisadores responsáveis pela
experiência e chamou o estado mental
daqueles cachorros que isso se deitaram
espera de mais choques de landi
helplessness o desamparo aprendido que
estado de alguém que é incapaz de agir
por si mesmo sem ajuda
mas por que aqueles cachorros ficaram
assim porque ele se deitaram espera de
mais sofrimento mesmo quando havia uma
saída porque eles aprenderam o modo como
eles enxergavam experiência passada lhes
ensinou que eles eram incapazes que lhes
eram impotentes
você vê como a desesperança poderosa
a desesperança nos paralisa a
desesperança nos mortifica ainda vivos
nós luz insensibilizados a decisão vamos
com a nossa dor ea dor do outro a
desesperança obstáculo na luta contra a
corrupção porque ela retira a nossa
capacidade de enxergar as oportunidades
do presente
nós nos tornamos e incapazes de mudar a
realidade mesmo quando isso é possível
sonhando ou usando e perseverando mas aí
alguém me dirá mas eu tenho como sonhar
o saae persevera veja o que aconteceu
com as medidas a cada jornal nacional
nosso nos choques e mais choques
elétricos
esse congresso não aprovar reformas
entre corrupção porque a maioria dos
parlamentares que está lá não vai
aprovar eles não querem mudar a minha
resposta é então a mudança está nas suas
mãos
se o congresso atual não aprovar um
pacote anti corrupção então em 2018
vamos colocar lá quem vai aprovar
enquanto nós conversamos aliás entidades
respeitadas da sociedade civil e sem um
seguindo sonhando ousando e perseverando
elas articula uma grande campanha de
corrupção para 2018
várias delas estão desenvolvendo um
superpacote a discussão para promover a
integridade no ambiente público e
privado
esse pacote vai além das medidas e
aproveita grande parte delas propondo
ainda por exemplo melhoras nas
licitações na transparência do sistema
político eleitoral na educação de
crianças e jovens e nas regras de
compliance
ele será submetido uma discussão ampla e
aberta com a sociedade civil e se for
aperfeiçoado e aprovado pelo congresso
revolucionará a luta contra a corrupção
no nosso país
a estratégia agora não é mais coletar
assinaturas é escolhemos como novos
senadores deputados apenas os candidatos
que possuam um passado limpo tem um
compromisso com a luta em que condição
com a luta tem um compromisso com
valores democráticos e além disso que é
importantíssimo nesse momento nosso país
apóiem o pacote de corrupção
a idéia agora é nós tomarmos windows o
pacote como um critério e na fas tável
para o voto que o cidadão conjugará com
outros critérios da sua preferência
não se trata mais de apenas uma campanha
de voto limpo
agora nós selecionaremos candidatos que
nos levaram a um conjunto de leis que
incentivaram integridade as quais o
tempo nos levaram a candidatos mais
íntegros o que tem de nos levar a novas
incentivo integridade inaugurando um
novo círculo agora um círculo virtuoso
para o futuro
o meu maior medo é que alguns de nós
muitos de nós como aqueles cachorros que
se deitaram espera de mais choques não
percebamos que em 2018 existe uma cerca
baixa sendo colocada perto de nós nós
podemos dar um grande salto contra a
corrupção no brasil
talvez você esteja achando tudo isso
muito bonito mas queria me dizer como
aquela senhorinha do avião a meu filho
isso aí não vai dar certo se você perdeu
as esperanças eu quero dizer que eu
entendo você mas eu quero propor um
exercício mental
pense na pessoa que você mais ama na
face da terra
talvez a sua mãe ou seu filho o seu
marido ou sua esposa
imagine agora que você vai ao médico e
ele me disse que essa pessoa que você
tanto ama tem uma doença terminal e
possui poucos meses de vida
o que você faz você vai pra casa
esperava morrer ou você vai fazer tudo o
que estiver a seu alcance para salvar a
vida dela indo de site em site de médico
em médico dobrando os seus joelhos e
buscando a cura ainda que seja
improvável
a verdade é que existem causas pelas
quais vale a pena se lutar
independentemente do resultado eo nosso
país é uma delas
lutar contra a corrupção é lutar pelo
nosso país e lutar pelo nosso país a
lutar porque nós mais amamos e nós
jamais existiria
os deles se o brasileiro é aquele que
não desiste nunca
vamos dizer aqui que nós somos
brasileiros e não desistiremos o nosso
país nós seguiremos juntos sonhando
usando e perceberam muito obrigado
[Aplausos]